it's good to be here it's good to be
away I was I've been in New York and my
parents just came to visit me it's a lot
when they come up my mother is
aggressively liberal like her dream for
me I think would be if I married a
Nigerian lesbian I think that's what she
wants she was praying that one of us was
gay that's all she's ever wanted just
one gay kid she was just sitting in the
kitchen waiting like there's Coco if
anyone feels gay and wants to talk about
it and whenever she visits me in New
York she always tries to bond with the
cab driver and apologize for Trump
it's intense she gets she gets off the
train with just a very jazzed up energy
she's always wearing some sort of long
menopausal cape and just she's just
ready to build some cultural bridges in
her Navajo smock she has one of those
overly spiked soccer mom haircuts like
her hair just keeps getting more and
more angular and furious she looks a lot
like vanilla ice at this point and
whenever she gets into a cab she always
reads the nametag she likes to bite into
an ethnic name and honor it she'll be
like excuse me Sara Han J what a
marvelous name what region is that I'm
like he's not a wine he's a man Karen
leave him alone the worst part of his
day is that you have access to his name
right now she goes I just want to say
Sarah Han J that I am so sorry for these
terrible things that President Trump has
been saying about Moslems I'm like
that's not the way to say it actually
I think that was the racist way to say
it she goes we think Muslims are
fantastic Sarah Hodge and you were
certainly welcome in my neighborhood
he's just glaring at her like I'm Sikh
you white [ __ ] get out of my she's like
you're welcome cultural bridge built
who's next
she has no ability to see how she's just
been received by anyway she walks around
horrifying people like what a
wonderfully inclusive quilt
I've been waving I can't relate like I'm
the opposite all over analyze the
smallest social exchange I'm extremely
sensitive which is why I like being a
comic is the hardest career if you're
really sensitive because any moment of
our lives can suddenly be wildly
humiliating like I was in the show in
Alabama in the middle of my show this
guy just stands up out of the blue and
he just goes you have a camel toe
I'm not kidding that happened that
happened to me and I didn't feel that I
did but I couldn't like look down and
analyze myself in front of the audience
and then this other woman stood up
across the room and she goes no she
doesn't have a camel toe I thought the
same thing at first
so now this audience is turned into like
a town hall meeting about my crotch and
now I'm listening I'm like well what is
it then you know like I don't know what
she's got to say and he goes no no
that's a camel that's a legit camel does
that crotch just fit to stomp through
the desert and then he goes and then he
goes that's her thing that's probably
like her little trick you know because
that's her hook that's how she flirts
with men and reels them in I don't know
what she's doing which is truly the most
ludicrous thought I've ever heard like
who flirts with men like that that is
not a known tactic like how would that
even work like I'm getting ready to go
on stage what not I'm not gonna hit that
stage before I do my golden trick works
like a charm I just stop and wink at
myself in the mirror like I always do
before I go onstage I usually stop but
I'm just like you got this babe because
I call myself babe a lot and then I go
wait not so fast let me just camel
myself
and it's show time girl
and then some he gets kicked out the
cameltoe guy which seemed fair it seemed
like it was time for him to go although
I still miss him sometimes but uh so as
he's getting escorted out of the room he
just stops and turns around he goes you
can't kick me out of here Tristana can
of hurt oh now he's called it a tow and
then he goes I'm not going anywhere my
cousin's served in Iraq which is the
most brilliant reason I've ever heard
just used your cousin's bravery to be
able to stay anywhere and continue being
a wild [ __ ] and then they're still
pulling him out of the room and he goes
I bet he never saw camera like that
knowledge travels
you